by Nestle by the way lesley we are we're
sponsored by my wife we're sponsored by
the up you guys hear that yeah oh my god
time what is it so continue yeah we're
sponsored by the company that's raping
us of water in California so what you're
saying no nestle everybody wants you to
quit but Bill Cosby what yeah Bill
Cosby's putting the drugs in the Nestle
water welcome to Hollywood anonymous
episode John 1 episode 18 cuz I'm 18
Turner huh that's Alice Cooper correct
no no that's is that who's visiting say
yes yes Alice Cooper's visit pissed hold
on let me chop off the head of my snake
I'll be right with you guys alice cooper
also loves animals visiting the show
today i'm marie a valor Val I told you
you just sit with Marie correct Marie's
now at Mert no Marie valor Valor feller
just don't Valerie Otto about Valerie I
get it right nope no okay by the way
this is this is every MC of course
middle America du so gay America where
right let's get it right first and then
I'll a salary ah no valeriano valeriano
local air park Vettel's it's that is the
bullets bullet valeriano how long even
doing stand-up oh boy I've been in
comedy for like 20 years okay so it
makes me think you ever go there you
know that's great the 20 year mark like
your set now and from what I've the
reason why the research of no way to
turn it off as I way looking I don't
know but I don't know why we let it go
solo that's that's a radio thing man oh
man you saw man thanks man it's a
guesstimation or 20 years by the way are
you watching baseball while the show is
going it's a Cubs doubleheader man
they're playing the Reds what do you
can't take just a second off I've taken
many seconds dude it doesn't seem to
bother you any way I can do it so
back-to-back sac tomorrow yeah but you
so 20 years of is what people often say
is kind of the benchmark of okay if you
can hang on for 20 years you'll be
you'll finally get to like a status
where you get a little more road work
and you began if you so choose correct
if you so choose yeah I mean you're
but i've been i've been involved in
comedy various forms and I just stand up
between writing and I got started doing
sketch in the clubs and then I didn't
get into stand up until two thousand I
nine two thousand and then I took like
four years off a lot because I got so
fried out so quickly so tech so but I
was writing comedy for television during
that time so it's kind of I was out of a
weird kind of trajectory what yes and
now i'm just all stand up valeriano so
here's the Cyrus so here's the day first
of all that's not true there you're not
I'll stand up you still write uh yeah
that's true yeah that's true yeah so
early on me stand up it ever get to poor
you just got so tired hua bastardizing
your name that you're that you did you
consider just giving him something else
on the stage I did I did Marie V for did
as a matter of fact some like every once
a mile run into an old timer I got
started with a be like marry me what's
up but um you know you go by Marie V and
people are expecting a.m. arivu right I
got that you figured out real quick and
I'm not that is not a fat dick elegant
turn so something so what were a
gambling golf shirt I just said [ __ ] it
let's do valeriano man you just dealt
with it and you'll just deal with it and
this is how I tell every MC before I go
on stage what do you want to say about
you blah blah blah an Audi surname I say
my name is pronounced Marie valeriano
however you say it is fine just say it
with conviction just say it like you own
it may be still showing up right yeah
it's like you're not going to go on
stage till they get it right not getting
my [ __ ] HBO our special at you know
and crackers in Indiana you know but I
mean when you get that special they'll
probably spell your name wrong yes my
name is John Huck and everybody spells
it wrong how do you spell Huck wrong or
John they spelled genre well you're the
jerk who doesn't put an h in it not a
jerk my full name is Jonathan the
shortened version of jonathan is john j
om only go by jonathan how about I don't
know how about build wire you guys know
bill dwyer he's gonna be on the show
that's actually bi oh oh he must just
his whole life then you're never gonna
fix well you're bringing that on
yourself are your parents or my feel
like he did that on purpose or no I will
find out I excellent happens that's
funny that you bring up I like to come
on and talk about other committees
approve the people who
beyond right after you by the way we are
broadcasting today from ya the herald is
dead no well I don't care about that as
much as it's that mean that in a bad way
I'm just saying where we are we're
inside my house in the kit not in the
kitchen or the dining room Dino so it is
look I don't know if there's a little
bit of a f'in echo is in there it's
because this is not a true podcaster
deal until my man cave gets built if
which will be what when the kids are
college when we we're thinking maybe
episode 1776 working at hollywood
anonymous I'm job Brian's dead I know
it's like one of the Hollywood anonymous
I don't know who I am as you have you
seen my pants uh we could say that now
technically well I mean yeah I'm
supposed trying to say the other day is
like I I know I'm old now like I'm I'm
40-something like this old man right now
but I also huh I don't feel like I was
like I was telling someone I was like
nah man i still like black out sometimes
and i still like piss my pants i'm not
think i'm not 40 like no dude you're an
alcoholic what is wrong yes another age
where you should hug yeah that's a weird
benchmark by the way just so you know I
felt like God made me cows like I'm
young I still do dumb [ __ ] well no
here's the thing and I'm not going to
speak for whether you're over 40 or
library but but when you when you hit 40
you have to remember though your idea of
what you think it is is coming from a 22
year old dude and like that you think
back then that dude is like he's over
the hill its ancient it's over and then
you get there near like I don't really
know and it's not this turrent denial
really not much changes I mean yeah you
start getting there certain things in
your body that's look you know that's
where your that's where you terrify me
like I read your posts and your poster
like all about how your body is like
dropping it but it does that's the truth
but i will say i am over forty so i can
agree with traffic but also and you're a
father yes sir but you surf regularly i
get well yeah as regular it's cut down
since i became a father sure do you Jim
it up do you go to the gym at all to you
my mornings are either gym or surfing or
sleep either see that the gym my point
was my point where i was going was you
know getting back to the gym and a
second finisher
you look a little more put together and
in shape than like me or a Brian oh
that's because as you can probably just
tell them I last question how are you
getting to the gym with children well my
way eh we only have one um plated still
want my wine right yeah 3 30 my wife and
I decided and we try to flip flop work
like while she works I'll stay home with
the kid and then while I work she'll
stay home with the kid that kind of
works I didn't actually work this year
because I didn't get a job during my
time off so uh so we decided that flip
stayed never came back to a flop is what
ya business more seriously mr. mom yeah
we're mostly on the flip but we said
like when she's working when i'm working
i'll get her a babysitter in the morning
so she can do yoga and then when i'm
working she'll get me a babysitter ok so
you can write i can go to the gym right
yeah that's what comics say when they're
not doing anything I'm writing yeah even
we've been busy I've been writing nobody
but even still and i think i think amore
would agree with this is that even
though you stay in shape the body does
not it doesn't have the aggressive
nature that it wants to so even if you
do exercising you do lift weights it's
not like you know your body when you're
younger you would when you worked out
for a while you'd see like change pretty
quick I've noticed some things it's just
I'm you do it now it's a lot harder to
notice a difference I'd go on a surf
trip to let say Costa Rica for a week
and I'd come back and I would just be
ripped Jack's all you did was wrong I
did sell and now man I can surf eight
days in a row and I'm still flabby guy
and it's funny you mention that because
I just had to I just had to uh cut
together a tape to give to a club and I
was headline in the irvine improv
whatever let me get let me get that fake
outflow I don't have a continued he had
no sound effects I was but he what I
didn't know who is gonna go for
grandstanding
I was trying to find something I wasn't
ready well there's a reason i say that
is because i had i'm like oh man I look
really fat in that bit i wanted so i
scroll through the hole I screwed the
whole thing oh man look really fat in it
and so now I'm like I don't want to send
this book or this thing has nothing to
pose like that I can't shut like has
nothing to do with the fact that i'm
killing like comedy cares about you
really want in shape comic cities right
well there are some clubs that it that
started that for a while which I never
understood that but that's the Jews
right no well in shape who thought there
was a guy okay so here's the thing i
don't think i don't care cuz i might eat
her in the in the in the comedy world
there was a short period time I remember
who the who the general manager was at
the comedy store there was a he went he
said to me I don't know if there's going
to be ruined here for you in the future
because you know you talk about raising
families and stuff like that and we're
moving towards young and in shape people
Oh Tommy no no this was somebody else
said and and wasn't i wasn't the Booker
was the general manager Bon Jovi's
brother I just thought yeah I was a seat
and I didn't say anything to out I
thought it was a stupidest thing I had
ever heard in my life it's [ __ ]
hilarious is it added cuz I'm thinking
of myself Rick comic nothing that you
said has anything to do with comedy you
just you just described somebody that
you want to go on a day trip I don't
know what you're telling if you're young
and in shape and good-looking you're not
doing comment now you're getting late
they were trying to do going to be a
model that's hilarious we're not we're
moving toward we're moving in a
different you raising a family your
flabby we're looking for yon it was yeah
six pound I've always said it's like
here's the thing I've always said like
if you don't get me or if you don't like
me conveniently that's okay just say
that right right don't come up with all
these outlandish I agrees ins why I'm
not gonna work with you like I'm not
gonna be offended you're not my cup of
tea is I know the comedy is flat for
every single person and Booker's as
talent pokers and general managers and
people who run clubs as much as they
want to say that they know comedy across
the board they don't it's always
subjective so it's just pretty much of
it it's their opinion or they just
follow the trends that's going on in the
business so it's like I'm not and that's
not even i'm not even insulting them
just saying that's just the reality of
how the business works if you see
anything outside of that you don't know
what you're talking
you know that phrase ghosting going
around right now well it's like
deserting you beat off and wait where
are your my kids just got home what guys
gather round ah go see there's a bit of
a spider-man house Oh will you slinger
yet okay I no ghosting is not generally
as disgusting and sorry hey listen we're
looking for a little cleaner humor yeah
I'm a younger younger more energy batala
games well they're everywhere we're
gonna do punch lines and sit watch what
makes it so but they're ghosts teen is
is what the kids are calling when a girl
or a guy will just stop returning your
text Oh making up a set of breaking up
with you and they call it ghosting I've
been ghosted by comedy club managers man
what are you talking about these new
it's nothing we knew but I just goes to
buy my managers my old manager just
stopped returning my calls and I like of
all the comedy I don't deal with many
Booker's or anything like that but not
i'm curious now like with statements
like that like we're going for a young
younger more inch if if there's a thing
like i don't how many across the board
and you gotta do push-ups to do comedy
like i just wonder if people are i'd
love to get inside everyone's head the
only Booker who I think like right now I
would go yeah that guy is [ __ ] doing
it right and he's creating an amazing
environment for comics and that's
Patrick Seether Milligan or Mulligan at
the stand in New York okay oh really
that guy is amazing did you be working
under stand and haven't been back to New
York Oh to perform and he is so he's
somebody that took it over or is this
somebody toys no he I don't think he's
always been around I kind of got put in
touch with him through Eric Abrams okay
Oh years ago and he I don't know if he
would like the stand was a restaurant
mm-hmm and then he kind of turned it
into a comedy club downstairs and it's
like every time I call him he's got
spots for me and every time I go to one
of those shows everybody there is
awesome okay you really feel like you're
like that's new york comedy like every
time i'm there judo Freelanders there
everything those guys are always like
Todd berries always all these people are
always there and it's very it's a
well-run club man enough just that I
think the way he does it is smart
however is no i think it's it's it's
never easy to develop comedian
it's very hard and I think you know I
mean it's like people that you know you
know comedians everybody's going to bug
you everybody's gonna try to cut down
your door everybody's going to look at
that stage time you know whatever
there's what on average do you know
seven to ten spots a night in a club in
this city sure not I'm not including you
know laundromats and you know off the
offshoots but right yeah but i mean it's
it's it's gotta be hard but it's just
it's a little bit disappointing that
because it becomes hard they just they
just streamline it and then it is stay
small and then just go they a lot of
times it just you just kind of go with
the trends which is again if you know
that going in right at your body you
just got to hope you you sneak in there
so well you got to relearn it to like I
was stoked like we're talking about the
Sun Mike I think maybe in a stay-at-home
dad this summer um so I was like sweet I
just released an album like two months
ago so I'm just going to stay in town
I'm gonna do all the shitty shows and
I'll do melrose and Irvine and probs and
I'll just work on you know my next hour
or whatever I forgot that everybody else
is in town this summer because it's so
slow stand up is so slowly the summer
nobody works so it's like the fight for
the stage time is ridiculous yeah right
now and it's not like I'm new to the
scene you know I every book there like
you've always a weird it's an
interesting thing to me with LA do you
feel that there's you never really earn
your place like you can leave for like a
year and then you come back and because
you've been around and you've been
established you try to get into some of
these rooms because it you know not all
them are booked by club right well
they're actually booked by other
comedians and that you just you're like
they don't care like there's no earned
position I don't think there's an urn
position unless you're unless I call it
you you win the comedy lottery right and
you become one of the comics that my mom
can name you know I might want to find
that people never so maybe yeah you know
but I also like you know if the reason
why bring it up it's interesting there
really is no scale right there's no
earned scale like you you put your time
in and then you kind of get then you're
in it doesn't work my way I'm going to
this right now like there's a really
shitty shitty club up north that I that
I'm like oh you know I'll do that in the
fall cuz i'm working on new stuff so i
emailed a booker she's like oh there's a
new Booker so I emailed a Booker and I
know he's gonna be like I don't have any
room for you like okay so there goes a
week that I'm not gonna be able to work
because a new booker came in and doesn't
know me
younger and I've been doing that club
for 10 years right so all of a sudden
I'm at the bottom of the because he
brings in his guys from winter he was
booked in less time it really is it's
like you like I've a lot of comics i
know of lived in a land and they moved
to New York I'm going to here as you can
get stage time every night do so many
shows they move back to LA in about a
year because tail between their legs you
starts you start at the bottle I've been
doing this since 2001 if I were to move
to New York now chances are i would be
at the bottom of the barrel and have to
start going to these you know you like
bikes agendas gotta start over baby yeah
i don't have it in me to start over nor
do I want to really live in New York for
that matter but um but I just it's just
weird how you can like you said you'd
stop for four years and in those four
years people just probably forgot about
you oh yeah and it's not because you're
not memorable or you're not a nice guy
is because everyone's so focused on what
they're doing that's like if you get out
of my if you're not my field of vision I
[ __ ] forget your router well the
simulator another good-looking white guy
comes in to do comedy I and then you
just blend into the back well that's
that's comedy tryouts now are like pull
up bars and it's like it's like the
health test you took enough to do a
comedy combined in order they get it he
runs what's his 40 what's his 40 time
that's too slow yeah he can't work this
club but he also doesn't have any
material what's his JPS sign up for
three minutes two minutes of jokes per
second Oh was that I just made that okay
I don't think that's a real thing
candidate it is now first of all gay men
who how many jokes need to tell per
second quickest jokes I've ever heard
just making fart noises into the mic
like summary fanatically what I'm
finding out here is that having a child
has complete [ __ ] your life up extremely
Mike I just want to get clear so
hopefully I'll you your Kittle is having
some kids just got engaged moment that I
was not prepared for another what you so
glad marriage equality worked out for
you and I'm close-minded it took I'm
homophobic um yeah no um odd but I don't
we haven't really we kind of talked
about kids like right after we got
engaged who's like I guess we should
talk about stuff I go maybe are you
sterile I don't think so
you sterile I don't think so y'all have
kids ladies over 40 G's held oh I know
her yeah so your LS that was an old man
thing right there how old is you oh I
remember her when she was this tall or
she's still making Daisy change now we
work together on it on a show a few
months ago and I met her she's a
sweetheart yeah a lovely woman a lovely
woman yeah this is in tamela's John is
all growns up now he turned 40 panicked
he's getting there I didn't panic okay
just check out it I want to make sure
she panicked yes no she was confused too
she's like what are we doing now I
remember I was sitting in an unset with
her and we're sitting by the producers
table and and she just liked it oh so
can you talk can you say what show it
was or do you not want to uh we haven't
care was 500 questions what happened
just now just trying to do sounded weird
ocean we're out me well well you're
getting ready to surf and okay just a
quick story before you run with the
ocean yeah well you get attacked by a
shark dude we'll talk about that in a
second all right you must have seen that
video oh yeah i was watching out live um
anyway so she's just telling me all this
stuff about John do one point I'm like
you know John and I aren't that close of
friends I did tulare asst to hear this
stuff an iced FYI his penis is crooked I
don't want to know that he is on my
podcast once what the what was she what
did she share that was not oh I'll get
John's getting all nervous now I'm not
nervous I'll say the nice one she said
oh which was that you're surprisingly a
neat freak oh yeah the nice one that's
all she said that was nice do you dust
all your tchotchkes as well ah death
where'd you go that far or you just
organized I'm very organized not a
duster I'm not a duster I try to hire a
cleaning person for that but I have
dusted and now i'm cleaning bathrooms
because we're kind of uh you know how do
you say broke as [ __ ] right now no can't
really bring it you know that knowing
that you hate the one thing you have to
understand this right now you can never
expect anybody to feel sorry for you for
the following categories one I can't
afford my gardener right I can't afford
the cleaning lady anymore understood dan
three I am tired of raising my kids why
can't I get a nanny no one cares about
any of those it's so funny you bring
that up my pool guy and I
a book I was raising my kid no I I
understand no was gonna feel bad for me
but I am financially uh if I can give
you some marriage advice you're in
rowland yes don't get married and
that'll save my finances no get a
cleaning lady even if it's only like
once every two weeks oh yeah no no
that's a good mirror that's good when
like when she has friends are about to
visit I do a one for marriage if I yeah
yeah no matter what they're going
through right now we just don't seem to
sleep together anymore you need to get a
clean get a cleaning lady have every
every once a month oh I forgot to get a
hot cleaning lady that's net Sadler's
the top right work pornhub.com and we
have topless ones out here is that or is
that it was young I settle all the way
you know that was a big you hire one
yeah I hired a topless cleaning company
all dudes they came in with my super
annoying I should read the nipple they
were really good at what they did their
vans out here that have their hot pink
vans as topless cleanly and I justice
for 99 bucks they're all in that van
yeah they all live in there only think
there's month beds no actually they're
all in the name Utley there in a
shipping container down by a long beach
waiting to be released that's [ __ ]
Hollywood anonymous law and order dishes
right cooking I was gonna say yeah they
all live in the van but on they dread
but then the van goes into a big
semi-truck like Knight Rider used to the
guy like their assignments and stuff
assignments here actually investigate
private investigators now they're like
isn't that well that was already show
VIP right with Pamela Anderson well
there was VIP and they were she spies
there's been a couple of not like
alcohol girl hot spies she spies sounds
like a weird video on no was it was a
show you know he's back before cable was
really like people watch cable now those
back when you know cable is question oh
yeah we'd like yeah I'm gonna show it's
on TBS TBS plugin what and now it's like
I'm on a show on TBS it oh good oh look
TBS's don't submit programming yeah not
bad all they need now is viewers yeah
it's true are they struggling yeah
that's the way I would even ask Honan we
have I mean I like Conan a lot man I
never watch it I don't I don't want you
start realizing the actual power of lead
in though that's the thing is actual
network television and the thing is is
network television I think until
if it ever dies I think just the way the
system is set up right now I don't think
there's room for another network to do
what Fox did which is getting the game I
yeah I think people the new generation
isn't even interested so you can't
you're not I just don't think anybody's
gonna be able to get televisions on its
way out and it breaks my heart cause
that's all I ever wanted to do you think
it's all the way I don't ever think it's
gonna go away I think the way we know it
is on its way out like the last writers
assistant i had is 25 never owned a
television in his life he just watches
everything online yeah yeah now they got
HBO to go by john i'm about to that i
really like TV me too man i know what
you're saying it's it's and I I
appreciate all the new outlets you know
what I mean I love like Netflix doing
original programming amazon doing I
think that's fantastic I think it gives
us more quality programming with less
[ __ ] restrictions that networks have
because the net with the problem is that
the network executives are going to end
up there they're the ones destroying
television sure because they have no
[ __ ] vision and they have no
originality and they have no balls and
they won't take any [ __ ] chances on
new stuff they're like give me some
rehashed crap oh yeah that's good they
put that on and then they wonder why
nobody wants to watch they canceled it
in [ __ ] two days right the thing is
is once the HBO laid the groundwork for
that and exposed the networks yeah by
saying all right we're just gonna we're
going to take a risk here we're gonna
let these people do what they do I'm
gonna let this thing grow we're let it
breathe and then net well Sopranos yeah
but then now you have these new ventures
that you talked about Netflix and Amazon
probably eventually hulu now that the
show time is bought it it's like they're
gonna lose their going to do things and
it's just going to just have this
glaring hole that networks are just
incapable of adjusting to well they're
also video it's two different things I
mean HBO is paid a subscription TV right
you know the top four networks or
whatever our advertising so you're not
just answering to your viewers you're
answering to how many corporations yeah
good night and the coop and television
don't trust me I'm not defending that
side of television writing job in town
the executor said just so you know
you're here to fill in the time between
advertisements yeah that's all you do
that and that's never changed but the
but the problem is they i think they're
a little bit too quickly influenced by
all these coal
Lycians that get involved and try to
shut us down and I just I mean if it's
weird what middle America likes
sometimes when you'd always it always
boggles my mind that like big bang
theory is a show that you know people
like my uncle are like but let's pretty
edgy Carmody you're like what no it's
not but then but then again who I've
gotten to the point also where it's like
who cares because there now are enough
other outlets to actually go get what
you really wanted yeah you know yeah
just I just don't watch three camera you
know sitcoms yeah I mean every every
genre of television has its heyday and
that's in the three cameras over you
know for a while there it was a sitcom
and then for a while there was the
hour-long drama you know for a while
there was the talk show the late-night
talk show for a while there it was a
daytime talk show so every you know
every founder has it says somebody was
just bringing up all these people those
names I had forgotten like Sally Jessy
Raphael oh yeah and I had just
completely Donna there was all are you
there Yeah right there was this whole
probably decade where it was dude
Letterman was a daytime talk show well
I'm saying but there was a decade where
the most famous people on television
we're doing daytime talk shows how about
that one she was she was a stand-up and
she actually won Ellen no no no now
she's a blonde she was a lesbian not
island someone else one else but she was
a stand-up and I think she won like Star
Search and a Star Search power surge in
like the late 80s and then she got her
own TV her own daytime talk show Rosie
O'Donnell no and then they outed
somebody on television and he killed
himself oh wow what uh it was uh not yet
uh only way I guess the inner zone of
cable I only if I had my net liked that
was between old guys [ __ ] about the
fall of television we forget we have the
internet access can we look that up on
the TV um i would say that wasn't Sally
Jessy Raphael now now I can't remember
her name Lisa Lisa Gibbens no no no she
she said she was an e like entertainment
who is the guy with little bit who was
the guy with the big mouth he died
Morton Downey jr. channel 9 secaucus new
jersey we heard to a taping their did
you really oh yeah there's a show
there's a movie coming out about him I
think it's at I think it's not or it
might be out maybe I
I don't have internet so I don't type in
talk show host suus there beside her
murder cuz one somebody got murdered
after I thought he killed him a celly
Jessy Raphael thing I've I did see it I
remember there was one anyway i'll just
type in the talk show host suicide and
let's see if hopefully uh on a very
special hollywood anonymous we google
stuff online that you can't see right
well no no i'm saying it out loud but
anyway so back to so Marie you're now
says me take it off something I you know
more about you you like Lee's um the
choice to stay home was was it yours or
was it was it genuinely just you know I
mean let's talk through that because I'm
always curious like I made my personal
choice tell my kids which I told you
earlier before we started the show I
actually think it's it's a great thing
and I just love how you're like yeah
everybody says that to me lets you know
step by dad staying around and being
there for just or 11 of the parents like
I just feel like if you can avoid
daycare one the cost is insane and there
you don't even know half of them yeah
I'm sure I don't and then and then to
like i love i love hearing at people now
kids talk about how pricey kids are guys
it's like nine dollars a week to have a
kid or it's like ten fifteen dollars a
week crazy but I'm saying like I if I
had kids I would prefer that me or my
wife hopefully raise them oh yeah that's
what I do maybe nine with like like I'm
here I got a sitter right you know I
understand that you got to get a sitter
just to save your sanity man absolutely
I met like just throwing them in daycare
or getting someone to just cuz I I know
people who have kenny jones Jenny Jones
that's it she was a stand of the gay
killer yeah i'm reading anything it was
a same-sex crushes controversy and stay
out of the person and they eventually
yeah Jenny joy she's gone man that's
effort yes I'm saying like these people
just gone well I mean I'm sure they took
their money and hopefully well no yes
your I remember I had somebody on my
podcast called wrote stories you can get
at retro TV on itunes for free we're not
right we're not doing the plug
I'm keeping the conversation go okay
this is how you talk to people wanted me
I want to be for the dead air a dead air
I was Larry on oh I was talking to
somebody who went up against her on oh
I'm start our search and he what I think
it either they were on my show or
somebody was telling me this story um
and they walked by her dressing room and
she's like inching her skirt up as like
as high as it can go for the sensors to
not yeah have a block and he looked in
turn his management goes and all this
time I've been working on jokes is
anyone in g1 the beggar more in shade
more in shape he was doing crunches yeah
what's always Wickard how I bet I could
get into some people's heads right if I
was just doing push-ups before a set
yeah you guys ready for this people wow
he's good I saw a dude back state it was
like a casino I'm sorry keeping this
microphone I don't know I'm doing but
you can get his podcast for that dude I
in murray you've you been doing you said
you started in podcasting when like two
thousand nine or eight or something like
that but there are there was a there was
a period of time I probably still going
on all will that do them on their phones
stop that please stop that your it's
like I know they call it the new
frontier we please stop doing podcasts
on your phone it's all about sound man
the sound quality that's if I hear
somebody's talking through a tin can i
turn it off yeah provides someone broke
into your house and is you know that's
my nephew my nephew Ben oh my oh good I
thought I was your one that is in town I
thought why no I know fish is playing
Saturday I thought mebbe ya know what
he's doing just got out fish to he's
actually downstairs barricaded
protecting you from the dog yeah [ __ ]
those dogs the dogs hate you oh yeah hey
we used to write over here a lot and
unbeknownst to Brian when he would leave
the room to go like help his kids do
something or whatever I'd be left alone
the dogs would be here and there but
they never know they always barked at
you though it wasn't like when you came
here they didn't bark at you know they
would bark when I entered but they were
for the most part for the first couple
days they were cool with me and then why
me I what's going on here to continue
and then one day I just started like
when he would leave the room I would
like her all right I would chase him
around and freak them out and get up on
the couch and at quarterback
they would just go nuts so that every
time I pull up to that point they would
just see me in the window back [ __ ] this
guy I told you I did that before I've
told this before so matter to you so
pissed off right now well because they
bark a lot and it's loud it's soup I
don't know I don't appreciate this at
Albright well you're not a dog guy you
have dogs what your dogs no I don't
imagine if you did the two children I
just brought my children my children
only bark it out of shape comedians yeah
dudes like me can't wait to walk into a
comedy club like what he's fat [ __ ] on
stage yeah is there any better more in
shape comic we're back no then you go
out back I'm in then I'm gonna go talk
to the Booker right now go guys I've
seen the fat [ __ ] you put up and let me
tell you what I'm losing what is it
what's the thing that the fat thing they
check out what is it Oh your act you're
a fat fat per second a half snps he's
got so much faster second fat per second
wait you were saying something I don't
know her al [ __ ] I don't know oh the
choice i bought the choice to stay at
home yeah joe stay at home dad thing and
have you seen it affect your comedy
immediately as well uh yeah it affected
my time I hold my album I just released
is an hour about being a stay-at-home
dad yeah and uh or actually it's an hour
about being a dad none specifically
stay-at-home dad so yeah it's totally
affected I mean how do you not deal with
it you're good you write about what you
know yeah and it's like you know and
went like remember when I got married
I'm like I'm not gonna write about being
married everybody writes about being
married to [ __ ] you're not but you have
to it's a personal journey moving with
you with Nicole you're gonna be writing
about living out that you already got 10
minutes all right you don't know what I
mean but but but that says to you to me
it says that your comic who because
there are comics who just write jokes
that are unrelated to them right all and
that's fine that's a sky it's a style
and and it says you know it's like you
know I think stanhope so this about but
the difference of carlin you got you
guys need to figure how do i do you guys
these clark hands um but let the
difference of carlin and prior is prior
talked about his life and carlin made
jokes like you wrote joke so it's like
you choose to talk about yourself so
before it was honest comedy about who
you were there's no way you can't talk
about having a kid
what you have a kid right there's just
no way you can't do it your material cuz
you'll feel like a weirdo because you
know what's going on your life and then
you're talking about like I'm a single
coked-up god no you're not you're
staying home dad talked about that a
single coked I gotta cut this short
against it I gotta get out of here I've
seen comics in the transition they panic
because they've been so used to talking
about one style whether it's like
they're this whole their whole persona
has been single or whatever or I just
never having kids and then when they get
that when something changes in their
lives and they don't know they don't
know how to quite accept the fact that
it's going to take a while to get your
get goin with that and they panic and
they don't know if they should be doing
it or not it's terrifying whenever you
if you talk about who you are on stage
and what your life is like it's
terrifying any big change you make like
about two thousand six or seven I pretty
much stopped drinking as much before
like I knew that powers guys before
shows comma it became became something I
was like I don't I'm gonna focus on
being funny and not being drunk you know
I need so we have to at some point
otherwise it was exactly otherwise I'd
be still doing what I was doing back
then I would be dead yeah but but so you
changed that and then all of a sudden
you're like [ __ ] if I'm not falling down
and piss in my pants all the time then
what am I gonna wear my jokes gonna go
like I have my whole thing was like I
liked it bharti and now I'm like I don't
really like to party that much I like to
stay home and you know you panic you
freaked out because you're like how am I
gonna [ __ ] write jokes you got to be
okay to fail yet you have to be okay
with failure oh yeah haha to god I'm
very okay and when you're right personal
stuff I've seen it happen to me several
times where you just go way too personal
and it turned in its and people like oh
oh and it may be holes I don't need you
guys maybe I maybe this guy should not
be on stage and maybe on a couch
somewhere talking about your therapist
daddy yeah just funny because we're all
three of us are talking about very you
know okay changes you're talking about
like not talking about pissing yourself
right right you're talking about yeah
maps are talking about having a kid too
yeah and then I'm thinking myself I just
was watching takes documentary where she
has to get up on stage and tell
everybody about my mom died I have to
press yeah like that's that's a little
bit i think that would be a tougher
transition i think as a comedian
yeah i mean look I've just said she
nailed that have you seen it by the way
I haven't watched it yet it's good I
watched her knock knock thing I thought
that was very funny I watched her Largo
I bought her Largo set oh nice or listen
to her larder which is it's what that
documentaries about it well yeah it's
just about all the things going on why
it was its it so it's it's it's a
different take on on on comedy which I
appreciate it well her knock knock thing
was great but it was because I kind of
expected they would talk about the
cancer stuff a little more but John door
was in it and he literally said so
you've had a rough year and she's like
yeah my mom died I got broken up with
breast cancer and then they never talked
about it again like that's a lot going
on in one year you bring that back maybe
maybe she had plans yeah they already
had because I mean that thing came out
pretty quick after the other one yeah I
think she had plans but um yeah come
back to your boo hoo story about raising
one child anyway I'm not the one who
yells at your dogs it's hot man turn
that anger somewhere else you know I'm
not to facebook doing the second half of
the show with the dogs in the world
that's what a great idea you want to
hear nothing of food your guests that's
fine uh let's keep the entertainment
value Roland that's at the same pace is
bring them out when bills here the very
end he won't know what's going on so so
you did you are you from here now I'm
but I've were you from I live in
California my home jersey but when did
you start surfing I want to move down
here okay yeah Wow on the back of a
truck on the way out yeah yeah that's
always on TV style on top of these are
my waves and you came out her because
just to get out of New Jersey's from
Jersey yes I I agree with that but get
out of its fastest you found out that if
you take a right turn versus a left turn
you can actually leave the city the
state so um but so when you came out her
eighth the comedy and all that stuff was
not the initial part of mass playing in
bands at the time so I'm good drummer
guitar player although I can play drums
to play drums in the marching band in
high school uh-huh the parade of tail
that brought me explains where your
comedy alright so so yes you start to
see you came out of her music yeah
actually I got yeah actually I came out
here with a chick with a girl and I work
out well I didn't marry her and she's
not the mother of my child fair enough
um she still see her
facebook this is being recorded yep now
like our plan was she was gonna go out
two months ahead okay cuz she need
another man she could stay well that
ended up being the plan but she was
gonna stay with her aunt and then I
would kind of get us an apartment that I
would come out and she'd get John then
I'd get a job and we live happily ever
after very detailed plan hey at least
you but it's more detail than most
people have and also completely
unrealistic but continue yeah oh yeah I
once you get here you're like I want a
job everyone's like yes so does
everybody else once you take a hike oh
yeah kula go get a credit card yeah
pretty non your life alright continue so
during that two months I was working in
Jersey saving up all my money and so
when I came out here she is still living
with her aunt developed a coke habit and
was bone in everything with a penis oh
fish code of your no place to live are
you talking about her aunt well I've
owned Durant later I Sarah know ya ain't
[ __ ] favor I could have it's a funny
part yeah I'm not with her aunt for like
two weeks cuz her aunt like took a
unique she took a shine to me she's like
sorry about my knees in such a funk out
it was all so similar or she got out and
then you live together a little bit and
then I found an apartment out in like
way way deep vanna and then that was it
for her you never saw her again I never
would be the point well no I know I mean
just to kind of check up on her what's
she doing now is she still boning dude
what's her address those who knows
actually she have a phone on me as a
giraffe looking to hire a coke [ __ ] for
my bachelor party what's her bps are
boning per second what's what rate did
you know that you buy no that doesn't
ask grant so yes I so that's how I got
out here and then and then I was just
like stranded and I mean like I don't
know about you guys but anybody I told I
was moving to California like a scene 6
nose dude well she one day before Ned
everybody nobody supports this nobody
supports the trip so I was like [ __ ] you
I don't live in my car for two weeks
exactly my brother live in a box in la
then go back to [ __ ] back home with
your tail and I was the stereotypical
just poor couldn't find a job lived in
my car for two week you know when
whatever was at the station wagon oh
well at least you could lay down well
not with all the [ __ ] in it bench seats
yeah yeah yeah cut the guitar the guitar
necks would go
it'll there so it was it was tough to
get the lay your head on it too right so
so so sir in those couple weeks though
did you go what did I just do oh yeah
I'm like what did I just do I say that
every day is never let go driving down
to irvine on a Wednesday night for hours
it was like you've been out here for a
while you didn't just do that but yeah
so you so so then what so like how did
you get your eyes got my uh my buddy
rich who I grew up with he's a good
friend of mine still talk I talked to
him on the way over today he moved out
here because he was looking for
something to do and kind of kind of
saved my ass hold that for one second so
other than the ant and the girlfriend
you knew nobody else out here that's
zero okay so you did have some other
fallback you never get anybody from high
school yeah I didn't come out here now
it's coming as a solo artist ok alright
alright so ok so now ever play well by
the way Hawk Tom I had to hock all my
equipment ah that's no is this I don't
wanna I don't wanna date you in any way
is this pre or post cell phone pre cell
phone free cell phones so how a couple
years oh yeah I'm little [ __ ] i-94
again so nice are you right but the
reason why bring that up is because
you're really stranded I mean your
payphone stranded right like oh yeah I
think I call your peso so how did you
connect with your buddy and kind of tie
all that together um just basically two
pay phones and then I got that apartment
so I had my phone turned on a little i
can connect to that and then heat while
i was in that really shitty apartment in
Van Nuys that's when he decided to move
out he's like lesson we'll get a decent
apartment you find a job pay me back
whenever you can kind of thing so easy i
was here we came out here and and
already had a better he had a job he had
a job lined up okay and so look at that
genius hold on estately that work out
for me need a consensus girlfriend
really did he really well him and his
girlfriend broke out who's now his wife
so the smart that he went back cuz the
end up getting married ago they broke up
back home they broke up I mean I think
he liked yeah so he was like I'm gonna
get out of here because we get out of
here can we finish the show with him can
you get him on the phone
seems like he's got a far more true
story the UM today Marie's friend rich
ah so it's so okay so you're out here
and you're doing the band thing now you
gotta keep in mind this is like I moved
a girls school this is like 20 years ago
right there right how school went so
when did you know you're not of college
or out yeah yeah okay so when did you
say all right I want to do this comedy
thing too well after i got after i got
like I forgot my [ __ ] together and I got
a table waiting job and I got a decent
apartment up and Franklin like where the
UCB is now I left there for like that
arias or whatever I said all right now
now that I got to do something I'm in
Hollywood yeah now I gotta do something
I can't go back I gotta figure what I'm
going to do with my life so I'm when I'm
music wasn't panning out or wasn't
listening comics are flaky yeah dude
musicians are the [ __ ] worst well is
it and it's worse because if you get a
band together there's oh there's four or
five people that you have to coordinate
yeah right as a comic there's one
[ __ ] involved three to five [ __ ]
you got a deal we hope nobody shows up
because you can do longer time we had a
better spot right without your band
you're not going on I think about so I
moved to Los Angeles where every
musician [ __ ] moves yeah so we were
close to that MIT school yeah totally so
so think about like the bands who have
made it like you too who met in the
seventh grade they make their doing well
they're doing all right you know and
like the stones and like all these bands
who make they all grew up together and
her friends so now you gotta weed
through the process oh yeah oh this
guy's an [ __ ] yeah oh this guy's is
racist this guy can't play I don't know
what this guys doing this guy's got a
coke will keep him yeah oops I think I
joined a Nazi punk band this is no good
so that wasn't working out at all so
Mike re and so and you weren't like
acoustic guitar at a coffee houses are
acoustic guitar a little bit and then I
gotta pay the bills yeah where does that
lead to right i mean comedy apparently
which also doesn't pay the point of
failure failure failure comedy and then
yet failure again yeah exactly but it
gets you and get you in the door that's
definite so so what was it that happened
that you want you know what I'm gonna
try this um I thought well first of all
I I thought oh maybe I'll get into
acting because I was doing some extra
work for some extra money and uh and so
I auditioned for like the American
major or whatever and I got in but it
was like ten thousand dollars yes so
that's like that's how yeah so I'm like
rock all right I can't [ __ ] do that I
can ask my parents are gonna pay for it
you know I you know have a good 10 grand
borrow 10 grand and sound like all right
what do I do what if I always done that
I like that I'm good at I've always made
people laugh so I start getting the open
mics dude there you go I remember your
first album like my first open mic was
the comedy store so you had to do the
two o'clock in the morning sign ups and
yeah yeah that's how they did it back
this we'll do that I don't think I don't
know would you what I'd it was a
certainty was really late at night you
hell yeah ok Freddy Soto who's now dead
yeah I lovely was a free Hooper nice I
went for three weeks and I didn't get up
things like next week and gonna have
like the eight o'clock spot I promise
was he running the okay but that was my
cuz I but before I did stand-up I'd
gotten into sketch through like I found
I found this little sketch group in town
and the guy to the guy run it turned out
to be just like I won't talk [ __ ] about
anybody except that girl who I moved out
here with her and this guy ok this guy
is such a lying scumbag which I didn't
learn till later on but he got he
managed to get his show a slot at the
ice house in the in the Annex when I was
the amateur room okay and so I was in
that and then he got fired and then the
woman's like who's running it was like
we're firing him and we're canceling the
show but you can come hang out and do
shows if you want so just you by
yourself yeah me and maybe two other
guys in the show you better sell be the
worst sketch group like six characters
at a time thing for them to a key give
you water over there buddy I tried to do
it non wreck the thing I thought you
were pointing at my I'm just pointing at
how awesome that counter
fun guns hey man really good job of it
and follow the story after we're done
recording um so yes so she said
basically thought you were funnelin
she's like come on back and then and
also your personality must have played
into that a little bit I would imagine
you seem like a busy guy wasn't a tick
I'm trying I try not to be a dick right
but if you realize that guy was a dick
you're like okay now I know never to be
like that dude yeah and this is when I
starting to realize he was a dick so I'm
so I had to kind of way and I was his
roommate at the time oh [ __ ] so I'd like
all right so this is the only thing I
have going for me is this ambitious guy
show ya ice house and this guy just got
fired and now I can take in the show hey
yeah and so now I know then what
happened so then he kicked me out I was
gonna say get the [ __ ] out of here she
did act in my car again no not back in
my car I got a little shitty one-bedroom
apartment now you always I I don't know
you I haven't known you for a super long
when i met your pretty easy guy to just
start a conversation with right you're
not you're not the kind of guy that's
that's always on you know guy that's got
the wall in front of you have you always
been that way when you first came out
were you a little more arrogant kind of
a sort of abrasive or you've always been
kind of i think about your kind of chill
okay maybe that's really that's why i
would if i met you on the street and
someone asked me where you were from it
just off the top my head us I think he's
from Southern California do you know
what I mean because I'm very relaxed and
you're not like oh people i mean i've
always been that way though that's good
I didn't have Italian from Jersey but
I'm not an Italian from Jersey right now
I'm say yeah i was born in memphis
tennessee to be all first of all so
that's cool you had no choice to try
music good point yeah a bunch of final
rest so many game between Elvis Presley
and Bon Jovi hey guys the boss they hand
the King the king and the boss so at the
time that you were you what you lost
your roommate and got it got a free and
got a free gig at the ice house um by
the way no car and no car taking the bus
Oh from from Hollywood to Pasadena so
it's it's cost there was no gold line
back then I see you a lot of time in a
little bit of money it's costing me like
yeah it's cost me like 75 75 hours so so
somebody said trying to get out trying
to get a bus from pasadena at two
o'clock in the morning oh man and i was
just going every friday and saturday
hoping i got on stage and i would i
would get up nine times out of the tank
okay but it was still like improv and
sketch and stuff like that ok so when
when do you
the first time you actually were like
stand up and like he wanted to do
stand-up how many jokes we like all
right let's do this or did you just did
you go and just pull off of the improv
stuff and just screw around and then I
just try to figure it out from there
well I ended up I ended up putting
together a show with a you know comedian
named Hal sparks yeah alright so those
me and Hal and another gal hosted talk
soup for the well right yeah yeah yeah
so as me and another guy we ended up
doing getting the regular slot there so
we're doing a combo of sketch improv and
stand up for like a year then we got a
pilot deal off of it oh wow back when
they're still doing that and uh that
right them know we're like most pilot
deals yeah it was yeah well that must
have been kind of like how many years
after that was was the you started did
that for you mean for when he moved out
here how long after you moved out here
do that did you finally get after I
started on the ice house is like a year
and a half two years a bet going to the
ice house there's a year in Mike you
know a robert e before well of course
but I mean too good to get a pilot deal
that's fairly that's an early excited I
was so early that when it didn't go I
had nothing else you were probably rush
so like agents were like so what else
have you done it like nothing ass you
know i'll be at the ice house again next
week yeah i get off the bus I mean so
when that would know where then we'd
reached our Abbey Road stage you know we
were also kind of showing up through
different doors and stuff like that and
and so we broke it off and like all
right stand up let's do it so you didn't
you weren't like all now I gotta do
something real you were like I'm gonna I
can still have fun no oh because of that
pilot I got a writing gig oh okay so I
was he started to figure so you were
actually one of those ones where you
were okay with writing something for
somebody else it didn't Bob that's a
that's a hard transition I think for
some comics it didn't bother me until I
stopped doing stand up for those four
years and I was writing on a show with
Bill Engvall for four years and he was
travelling to stand up shows in his
private jet and I was like yeah so what
were you while you're writing his jokes
you're writing Tanisha your the temple
dis TV shows you what was it was the
billing ball show now he had it for five
shows at one time wow so I did the
here's your sign awards i did i did
country-fried which was a precursor to
clip shows it was like one of them one
that was that brought america's funniest
home videos on tosh point-o kind of it
was the meeting of the middle there okay
so we started using YouTube and said
home videos and stuff like that nice
that was like that did seven seasons of
not having to worry about getting a job
where that's pretty fantastic cuz I
don't watch TV but what where was that
that was on CMT okay by the way that was
all these shows run see him I can leave
you my resume and you will know if
there's a hundred shows on there you
will know to but you got paid for all oh
yeah all that matters we will know too
and like you said seven seasons and not
having to worry about work that is
almost anything it was like oh we're
getting picked up next season so we're
gonna take autist off and we'll start
back sometimes I didn't start shabbat
but you only think it personally just
bothered that you could not do stand-up
that was the hardest thing Rick it was
like I was reading jokes and I was like
oh this is a good one okay you know and
then and so that's what but then it's
funny having written for Bill and his
voice I would go out and do these really
funny jokes but I'm not a redneck right
you know so you don't have the accent no
and i was born in Memphis I didn't live
there for 15 you know what i mean so i
tried to play that card for a little
while and that wasn't flying and i don't
think a lot who understand that when
you're writing also those are long hours
it's not it's like this is not glamour
time no no oh yeah no this is and I'm
sorry writing comedy is hard it is very
much difficult you know what I mean like
it takes a certain like you know I don't
I don't know if I have what it takes to
be a writer on a show necessarily you
know the difference between like if you
write drama it can fall flat but it's
still okay listen it was okay you write
comedy and it falls flat with this
quarrel talk yeah sort the drop off is
unbelievable oh yeah and people like I
was just really follow michael ian black
on twitter is very very funny i'm always
been kind of a fan I don't know the man
personally yeah not where we're running
low we only have was a drought Murray
[ __ ] about 78 more I know why there's
a drought all the waters in your [ __ ]
living room but uh but I bet he was used
he's on the Jim Gaffigan show he ends up
on a lot of these shows like as a kind
of a side character or whatever but he's
on the Jim Gaffigan show which i watch
cuz i think jim gaffigan very funny and
whatever I watch a lot of TV and I was
following on Twitter and somebody just a
random guy with like 40 followers is
like nice try Michael Ian Black but you
[ __ ] up the Jim Gaffigan show too I
could write a better show and then
instead of just ignoring this guy he
engages the milk or he's like well I
just went through your twitter feed and
I
highly doubt that but I love your ideas
it was just like but people think
they're like and I mean I was guilty of
that as like a kid or I was like a
younger man to like all this show socks
I could make a better show okay go ahead
give it a shot it's [ __ ] awesome
really really and i'm at i'm at that age
to its like people are asked cuz I most
enjoy our work out like in the
alternative and not like realis like you
know like clip show I did that clip
she'll run with just CMT alone for you
know four or five years and then this
shows that spawned that was another five
year so I'm just a joke writer that's
what I do be like wow don't you want to
get on a sitcom like no I don't want to
write for a show that I hate I can't
think of a sitcom that I like right now
that I want to give up my life for I
want to dump my kid off at a daycare
right and go right for some show that
sucks I break for John Oliver in a
heartbeat well right well yeah yeah
that's why a if I was talented enough
that's let's put that out there it's not
like they offered and I said no no
that's a great that's my favorite show
on till it's really it's to me it's the
replacement of the daily show as far as
i can tell cuz you're on HBO he can do
whatever he wants and it's what's once a
week and it's everything that happened
that week and he's his writers it's a
very good well-crafted yeah he's got a
great presence and great voice man and I
never bought Jon Stewart I always
thought jon stewart was just it was his
writers but John Oliver I by I liked the
only time i was also don't smoke pot and
I always feel like you need a smoke pot
to enjoy Jon Stewart that's I'm have to
talk to my parents because they watch it
and I didn't know your parents are
getting ripped weeks to sell it out of
the ice cream truck right give me a
Frogger a bomb pop in a lid and a lid if
that's even dude the word lid my dad's
friend I didn't know you guys are
talking about might be coke is a lid
Nowell it is weed it's like it's like a
I still doesn't Alice it's an i think
it's an ounce of we announced cuz I
remember I was like going out with my
friends I was like 16 and my dad's body
was over there I think they were
drinking beers that I got caught with
and they were like hey all right hey
thanks for the beer and like laughing it
up and I was on my way out the door on
this guy goes Paul shots cuz where you
going ago i'm going over my friend
chris's he's like you guys gonna go buy
a lid just start at the left
started laughing because I knew all this
shitty terminology from back in the day
cuz I wasn't grateful dead fans i'm
reading all these books are was like man
we had grass it was the hippest thing
you're like okay brass annelids got it
just funny you still smoke pot oh yeah I
can't oh yeah stop by a good way too
excited about that I'm not excited are
you a card carrier oh yeah okay well you
know I don't carry the card because the
card is useless and most phones on it
but you know what i mean by i say that
all right it's uh it is you get clean
you won't do anything because you just
don't you know having kids that does
change a little bit you can smoke when i
do i do any it's in your brain right i
just wish i could smoke weed it's just
too powerful now I used to smoke old ton
a weed when I was in high school and I
was $25 a quarter and yeah yeah found if
I need my dime bags and gave you a
headache yeah yeah you're rolling huge
like little huge joint Meg like cuz
that's kind of that's gonna take to get
you high right now you're like one hit
like yellow yeah well then I got real i
did straight edge from like I don't know
95 to like 2001 or something like that
were in drink smoke or do any drugs and
in that time the chronic came out oofta
and then I went to it back to smoke pot
I was like this I'm gonna cry yeah it's
like I laughed for a half an hour I get
really depressed and then I kick
everybody out and I go to bed and cry
like it's just way too powerful for me
and you learn when you get bad drugs
there's no tech support like you can't
call those people will have them walk
you through it they don't have like
special your stoner buddies they just
make funny yeah then you feel worse
about yeah I was like me the riot a
joint shut up already you're ruining
everybody's i I just I stuff are you
with this guy I can do a little bit of
party when I when I first got out here
partying means coke yeah okay Brian oh
well yeah but when we were like when I
was younger like Haiti party I mean I
didn't mean like hey let's go get some
beers it was like you party that's a
rate up go that's a straight of coke
reference okay all right I didn't know
but it wasn't I since I do it was at
least like something drug-related look
no one just wants to know if you're
hanging yeah right you party yeah I like
to listen to music and eat cake I have a
funny hat yeah I'll bring a noisemaker
time should we all yell surprise her
but we stood there like a lot of ecstasy
and stuff was still really hot in the
90s and so we do all that and I had this
one friend who were to be like three
o'clock in the morning and everybody be
sacked and I'd be awakened if you'd just
be the one guy like this is the downside
it drugs and just like ruin everybody's
night like what thanks buddy I've always
the last one up I've got a problem oh
I'm just gonna fall asleep just shut up
man you're bumming me out we had a good
time tonight yeah this is what they
don't tell you about now they do they
tell you about it it's actually in the
[ __ ] manual use up all your serotonin
you're not telling me about suicide
Tuesdays and then you realize he's
wearing a mad t-shirt you were a plant
doctors gonna say we're gonna party with
people don't party with permanent extras
no man and weird moms again oh not mad
magazine oh just something with my mom's
Against Drunk Driving hey well just in
general they come from the vet ilk mobs
against dopey drug that's right mom's
against goops on gap get all goofed up
on cop I'm not here to down here to
promote drug use no no no that's not
what we do on the show it's just heard a
party where else adjust your cut cut on
lines of coke yeah so anyway oh my god
man can you feel my teeth girl I wanna
miss Hollywood anonymous enters its
fifth hour gasps we do not Mother's Day
let me take a listen you look we can
hear you sweating through that show how
is that working so Murray what L week as
we as we come to a close which by the
way you're easy to talk to it doesn't
say that was super quick it does when
people know what they're talking about
himself through another hour we've only
heard him say we got to the 2000s man
yeah so in a perfect in a perfect world
you would rather write or you'd rather
be a touring stand-up comic you you'd
rather be a stay-at-home kind I know
stay-at-home dad but a guy that's with
his kid does stuff here like what's I'm
gonna say something that you're probably
either gonna boo or call me cheesy and
say but this last father's day my wife
said what do you want to do and I said
what I do every day which is surf
hangout with my family do stand-up and
right ok so you don't want to go you
prefer to not go on the road and go
ahead and do it yeah well I'd love to go
on the road and I go on the road about
once a month then I'm gonna be going to
hitting the road a lot in the fall so I
kind of like what I'm doing now I mean
I'm not a big
find the happy medium if you will yeah
I'm not a household name but here that
has its downfalls too but look if you if
you're able to like helps while your boo
by the way yeah why wouldn't he [ __ ]
like surfing is a better time with his
kid what a [ __ ] gonna come off queer
I don't know yeah what a [ __ ] I woulda
shot bringing the dogs get him out of
here but you know no blows the show
bringing the dogs they just run up a
door um Bobby I cells this weekend i'll
be in irvine the following week i got
two weeks doing some stuff for jimmy
fallon in September so and I'm gonna go
surfing tomorrow and forget the first to
guide people but in September he'll be
doing some stuff with Jimmy found cuz i
was talking about what he's doing in
general i know but it'll turn I'm just
saying so I kind of doing it I would
just like to do everything on a larger
scale so were you let me fence yeah it
does but i mean i would like to not
drive divine but playa fly a private jet
to irvine right but you're also not i
mean you'd be content if you were you
know you can support your family you may
get all these things that you love to do
and you know you're not struggling in
the sense that some people are
desperately struggling well i'm also
very fortunate to have a woman who has a
career also sure with our combined
careers well that's it [ __ ] captain
clown over here he's his wife is a
lawyer yeah was that your nephew captain
clown yeah he's i'm making them in the
middle of we're at a day off and making
want to be right now so I brought him in
to help me with the with the film he's
PA and on the movie that him how nice
yeah p.eng we all know that means having
safety meetings AKA dope-smoking
sessions and the back of the grip truck
hey uncle brian my hair's growing how
can you feel that happen where'd you
head of that conversation or layout
don't do drugs on my movie set no i'll
let him speak for himself in a future
episode i was like what it's like to get
work with Uncle Bry cuz I worked what I
work with uncle bride and get any
lectures yes cuz you're not I'm related
yeah you're like do whatever you want
kill yourself on the elevator I don't
care died on You Man Man you ever he's
good buddy you're hear the stories of
the guys who worked in movies and TV in
the 80s there's just a budget there's a
climb budget for coke and it was just
non-stop party when I roommate talked to
a guy who was a PA on the Dukes of
Hazzard whoa and he said he would not
talk about a marketing
what destroyed oh and he would go and
get for overtime they would pay the crew
in overtime in cocaine and he would go
get it in waukee cases bring it in and
literally they would put it in a bowl at
the craft service table so people could
just come by and do it that's how old
like hey what are you doing oh no man
got some coke so probably just staying
in hanging out like okay Danny era yo
Sam Lee postcards from the edge no i
never did actually it's keri foods
basically carrie fisher's story yes yes
yes she wrote and she wrote based on her
life and it's just all about how she got
wrapped up in drugs in Hollywood not
much of them what we got oh that was the
time man so much party I missed it now
you're lucky if you can get caffeinated
coffee yeah well no you're not see if
you could caffeinated coffee it's okay
to have it as long as it's organic
Ronnie identified and you actually get
the names of the people that pull the
beans for you and then it's ok there's
cage-free and farm fresh [ __ ] out by
chickens chicken peel it with names
chicken names array thank you so much
you guys thanks for having me and uh
right now is the time anything else do
you want you have you got your show road
stories which is a great podcast that
I've done before oh yeah you can get it
at Road stories TV and I you can
subscribe on iTunes it's free it's all
great comics who come on we just hang
out and do this but we just instead of
telling stories about you know Brian's
movie we talk about the road and the and
the weird drugs and creepy women and
stalkers and stuff that dream on the
women I've never and yeah that's it and
then you can I met Marie V on Twitter
and I'm Southern California bound till
October and then I hit Chicago where
vein we do it in Chicago the improv oh
nice it's outside Chicago ya think
schaumburg yeah they call it a Chicago a
prop it's like 45 minutes to an hour
that's only ever get to see Chicago I'm
gonna try and go out a day early you fly
over it there it is oh we flying so much
fun yeah you should have you ever have
you never been I you know I said it yeah
I grew up and I grew up I lived in
indiana when I was a kid like two hours
and I talked about it never got the
stories of chic like no I never went
inside Chicago proper but my first
baseball game was at Kaminsky Comiskey
Comiskey got wet socks Comiskey and even
at like eight
like this place is a [ __ ] oh yeah I
thought it was never been in a baseball
every idea was that was my very very are
the first time ever saw baseball game
lab my dad took me to a White Sox tigers
game that i won tickets to somehow on
the radio or something rotting wooden
fences basically is like a rotten green
yeah it was I remember just being there
i feeI feeling like we were the only
ones there you know a rainy day and I
could tell my dad [ __ ] hated going
down it's just like [ __ ] but it's that
when they were short no my god that was
i still bring up those pictures all the
time I'm a Cubs fan so making fun of the
White Sox is kind of funny to me but
they were shorts for half a season in 85
oh really oh yeah I know it's all his
fault and big collars yeah they sit with
colors yes why did you scrape the [ __ ]
out of your legs what they found out
real quick quick yeah they look like
like female softball players effect was
a he liked to be a showman he he pushed
show before well that was all and that
was obvious he was still owning right or
no was he not was Reinsdorf warning if I
then I don't think Reinsdorf owned it by
then but I was Harry Caray still
announcing because he was a wipeout i-85
no no 85 boots with the cup you're right
because I was old enough to be yeah
something else I did I mention earlier I
join the marching band yeah I have no
idea we people said I was in marching
band too I played the Coronet Oh
everybody I was kicked out of the band
and seventh grade well my name's yes to
be about the music cause it's a motley
crew Dr Irwin behind the music is
marching band behind the oboe you're out
[ __ ] all right well thank you for coming
to my house thank you for a thank you
for not taunting my animals that's been
me my wife works like two blocks over
say so Brian don't talk to his wife okay
fair enough yeah we were a layaway if I
see her to work let's don't actually
there's a fence ki told me what she's
doing good i don't know i can do that I
mean Vince peace it don't matter a
dollar bill what do you terrorist Beulah
it's only a matter of time before we're
all live streaming each other no there's
no espera school Brian as he goes and
checks on Marie's life I love periscope
we did a pair of sculpted Africa's my
things oh I'm thinking about getting a
periscope yeah yeah I mean it's random
you don't have breasts so good luck
anybody know what gentle washers oh yeah
that's a good unless you make IPA then
you'll get them but the thing is I read
that yeah don't that's true man
everything else am I read it I read the
headline
you need a saw it it's going to be
repeated below whatever like 40 under
glass where we thank you very much
thanks for having me guys a lot
appreciate it man thank you for
listening to Hollywood anonymous don't
forget to follow us on twitter at
hollywood and nany that is short for
hollywood anonymous you can also follow
john individually at John Huck and
myself Brian or when at Brian or when
our Twitter as well both of us can be
found on facebook you can also google us
and contact us directly Hollywood
anonymous guys at gmail.com thank you
again so much for listening and please
don't forget to subscribe